[Music]
[Music]
i don't know how everyone else is
feeling about it but that final manhunt
cutscene with kelso and manny just
seemed a little bit off to me
there isn't anything immediately obvious
that i can point out there were just a
number of small questions i had after
watching it
i'm going to replay it just so we have a
reference point but please feel free to
skip this part
we need to talk
bro so you're talking to me again you
buddies in new york too busy to take
your call i finished decrypting lao's
insurance policy did you tell you why
she did it
there's no way she can justify joining
black tusk and assassinating the
president
when did everything get so complicated
the minute one [ __ ] decided his
christmas present to the world was a
global pandemic
[ __ ] amherst
we've contained that threat but there's
a bigger one on the horizon i know
whatever the true sons have been
fighting what faye was helping them
fight what she was trying to warn us
about
she figured out what was really going on
and she tried to warn us
but we didn't get the message
she tried to give us a clue back at
coney island and an ally
where's schaefer
same place he always is what's his
status
stable but in a coma been like this for
weeks and we're just tube feeding our
enemy
he's not our enemy
not anymore
manny
he's the key
she left us a key and if we want to stop
what's coming
we need to wake him up
[Music]
[Music]
manny ortega was in washington dc when
the outbreak hit
during the first days before the total
collapse of society manny's uncle was
killed by two future members of the
hyenas
after this point manny spent his time as
a signalist in the jtf
he slowly rose in rank mainly through
attrition
his superiors for one reason or another
left their positions and he took their
place
it is assumed that this is mainly due to
death and desertions from the green
poison or maybe they had received some
sweet pc additions and have struggled to
pull themselves away and get back to
work and on that note a big thank you to
nvidia and galax
they recently sent me through a couple
of much needed upgrades a geforce rtx
3050 and the glax virvence 1 gaming
monitor
out in my studio the 3050 is a massive
improvement over the old tied graphics
card i've been running it features ray
tracing dlss reflex and is exceptionally
quiet which is certainly going to help
when it comes to voice recording
back in the main office i'm embarrassed
to say that i've been a 60 hertz player
up until now which apparently is just
madness in this day and age but i've
always invested in pieces that would
help me produce better quality videos
rather than what i can actually see
myself
but after firing this bad boy up i'm
disappointed i didn't upgrade years ago
the glax gaming monitor features a
borderless 27 inch qhd ips led screen
165hz refresh rate one millisecond
response time with advanced motion blur
reduction and is g-sync compatible
basically my eyes are very happy with me
right now
a big thank you again to nvidia and
galax for sponsoring the video
manny eventually became the division
coordinator playing a role similar to
fey lau in new york city
many quickly wove himself into the
fabric of the division in dc
he still has some family in california
but he is not able to contact them at
present due to shd network issues
the scene starts off with manny having a
bit of a tantrum because he's feeling
neglected by kelso due to a time in new
york city
but in the timeline of events kelso
actually hasn't been gone for very long
plus given the importance of the mission
it seems a bit of an overreaction
to be fair he's always been a bit of a
panicker and overreactor
if i can't get more pieces from the toy
store i'm not gonna be able to finish my
[ __ ] match all right manny
but this seemed a lot more than usual
we've never seen him quite this tightly
wound up is he really just that upset
about being left behind or is he angry
with her because of some potentially
questionable decisions he's had to make
in her absence
and he blames her for putting him in
this position
i'm predicting that one of these bad
decisions is going to be the reason for
some challenging times in a future
season in dc
so whatever he has done whoever he has
spoken to
this scene is leading us towards many
having a much larger part to play going
forward
at this point after the countless times
i've spoken about her it might seem like
i have some sort of personal vendetta
against kelso
but in all fairness to her after
watching that scene quite a number of
times she seems completely legitimate
though it certainly wouldn't hurt for
her to blink every once in a while that
intensity is terrifying
i also believe faye when she said that
kaoto was the best agent she had ever
met
although as a side note that [ __ ] cuts
deep man i worked with you for months
faye clearing out multiple hostile
factions and cleaning up the streets of
new york in division one i'd like to
think i was right up there but that's
fine it certainly makes me feel less
terrible about the fact that i one shot
you at camp white oak
however i can't help but feeling that
something still isn't quite right about
kelso
firstly i can't seem to forget about
some of the earlier comms that were
released about her
don't we have enough agencies in this
country it's not so much an agency as a
kind of stay behind movement a last line
of defense if you will
no hierarchy and you'll answer directly
to the president and i'll get to do
whatever i want
whatever is needed ms kelso should you
be activated you'll be given
extraordinary judicial powers to
extraordinary judicial powers huh
all right sign me up i'll get the
paperwork started selection is six weeks
from now good luck
i've never scored anybody that low
imagine how bad things would have to get
for director 51 to be activated
every other option would have to fail
every single one that you tell me kelso
isn't exactly the kind of person you
want beside you in a scenario like that
she's pathologically insubordinate
that's an exaggeration she's only
insubordinate to people she doesn't
respect are you listening to yourself
well it's kind of the point isn't it tom
you don't call in the division if you've
got a solid command structure in place
and if you have a failing command
structure the last thing you want is
someone who's going to blindly carry out
bad orders i've already passed her
i'm just praying i don't regret it you
won't
well let's hope we never have to find
out
and then there is her past
even some of the more minor characters
or short-lived hostile faction leaders
have had some detail around the earlier
days
with kelso we have very little to go on
we know that ilani kelto was born and
raised in kawai in the state of hawaii
when she was a child she lived through
hurricane aniki and was left without
power for several weeks
she joined the army out of high school
and would later become one of the first
woman to complete the us army ranger
school where she demonstrated an
aptitude for out-of-the-box solutions
and foul play
this made her highly attractive to the
cia and for some years she performed
covert operations as a paramilitary
agent in the clandestine service
there she acquired a mixed reputation as
some of her superiors found her methods
questionable even though she always got
the job done
she was eventually recruited by the
division and she worked as an instructor
before taking on active agent status
but this is all very vague
other than an incident with a hurricane
we hear nothing about her earlier years
or her parents or other family
or just generally any information of
substance before the green poison was
released
while seven people did die after
hurricane aniki hit none of them
appeared to relate to kelso
with one woman dying of a heart attack a
man by flying debris a woman who was
crushed by a house collapsing two
japanese nationals drowning after being
capsized with another being swept out to
sea
and a man who died in his home after it
caught fire by a candle
all other characters have hit some sort
of traumatic experience that has been a
part of why they joined and continue to
fight to this day regardless of what is
thrown at them
it seems very strange that we have a
character of kelso's importance and we
really don't know that much about her
so after hearing all of that i'm going
to throw something pretty crazy out
there stay with me
what if kelso is a little closer to
natalya than we think
natalya is another one we don't know
much about
originally i was querying whether maybe
they were the same person altogether
but after a little research they don't
even have the same voice actor and their
mannerisms don't really align
but why do they pick an american voice
actor to play natalia
her half-brother felix and kelso this
makes sense as they grew up in the us
but we are led to believe that natalia
grew up in russia why would she not have
a russian accent
now i get it accents are hard a number
of you may remember the couple of times
i had attempted an american accent and
it was atrocious which is sad because my
mother was born in the us
but i'm no voice actor
perhaps there are deeper ties between
kelso and natalia
half siblings
full
i don't know
but have always been suspicious since
reading through felix sokolov's
information where it is stated that
felix was the youngest child and only
son of his late father
it seems like an interesting way to say
that felix was the youngest child of
alexi sokolov
by saying only son it sort of implies
that there were multiple daughters
but we only know of one so far
natalya
i am by no means fully invested in the
speculation with natalya and kelso there
really is no decent evidence to support
this i'm simply pointing out some of the
holes in the story so far that may not
have been considered up until this point
summing up whether intended or not i
think something strange is happening
regarding that conversation between
kelso and manny
aside from that i'm pretty stoked that
bad and shaffer is still hanging in
there he would have to be one of my
favorite still living characters in the
game right now
imagine if later on he starts
coordinating our missions for us here's
some of the best lines in the game
anyway this has just been another
tinfoil hat moment brought to you by
well me
i really must thank my wife after my
accident i really haven't had the
motivation or confidence to get behind
the keyboard or mic again
a lot of these ideas have really been
spurred on by her
she isn't one to be in the spotlight as
such so you won't be seeing her jumping
into any videos but do me a solid and
thank her in the comments if you can
ngn may be my voice and obsession but
she is the true force behind the
majority of these videos
thank you once again for tuning in and
i'll catch in the next one
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]